[Music]
since march more than a thousand
restaurants have closed in new york city
not because people stopped eating but
because the city and state have crushed
them with coronavirus lockdowns
but that number apparently isn't high
enough for some politicians in new york
they've decided to close
all bars and restaurants after 10 p.m
unless it's for
a dance party celebrating joe biden
otherwise it's very dangerous that
according to the party of science
tyler hollinger is the owner of the
festival restaurant in new york city
opened a couple months ago
even though the city has done everything
it can to wreck
his livelihood at the time we spoke to
him a couple of months ago he said new
yorkers will survive
are they tyler hollinger joins us
tonight tyler thanks so much for coming
on
how are you surviving tucker it's so
good to be on the show again
thank you uh tucker first off i want to
say thank you to you
and i want to say thank you to your
community because after i came on the
show the first time
the overwhelming support love compassion
of your community
buying gift cards coming to the
restaurant was absolutely
mind-blowing and it is a testament
to the beauty of humankind that we look
after
one another and i want to say thank you
well thank you for saying secondly
we have the best viewers
you have the most amazing viewers and
this kindness
is overwhelming and the gratitude is
amazing
de blasio and cuomo will not stop us
let's be clear they will not stop new
yorkers they will not stop new york
businesses
because they are temporary individuals
and the businesses
and the people that live in new york are
permanent
that's such a nice point i i wonder in
the short term though they're still here
can you make a living if you have to
close at 10
10 being the hour at which coronavirus
becomes dangerous apparently
yes apparently those out after 10 get
coronavirus
yeah apparently what cuomo doesn't
realize
is that those individuals who wanted to
dine late are just going to come an
hour early on top of the people that are
already there so what you've created
is a bad situation for more crowding as
opposed to
allowing people to spread out over time
enjoy their meal
now people are going to be more on top
of each other
which is insane this government
just allowed thousand person rallies to
happen
for joe biden all over the city but yet
you can't have thanksgiving for 10
people
something is very very wrong you make
such a good point about
forcing people to eat in larger numbers
when you constrain when they can eat
did you tell the city that or the state
that did they consult you
before shutting down your business at 10
pm
the city has no interest in hearing what
small businesses think
every day we are visited by another
government official
trying to shut us down trying to impose
fines
legislations restrictions when we're
just out there keeping
people safe and this is the hypocrisy we
are living in right now
but i can tell you one thing the power
of love
the power of kindness and respect for
one another
trumps anything that any of these
politicians want to say
because it's about neighborhood and it's
about community and protecting those
who you love that's that's an inspiring
thing to say and a great thing to hear
tyler hollinger we are rooting for you i
refuse to be negative about this tucker
i remember to be negative oh
and we have a drink for you a perrier
waiting when you come
so embarrassing that's actually what i
drink thanks
i appreciate it